you know what's interesting there's some
some cool physiology around this the
reason he needed to eat so much is not
that he was burning that many calories
in pure movement it's that when you do
exercise in water even if it's warm
water the heat transfer in water is
greater so you burn far more calories
and again here i'm i'm admittedly
lifting that from uh knowledge that was
passed on to me by tim ferriss i didn't
so but i checked it out and it's
absolutely true so if you exercise in
water even if it's not really cold water
your caloric needs go way up which is
why you get out of the pool and you're
often really hungry and for fans of the
human lab podcast and if you're not a
fan what what what are you doing with
your life uh
you would probably chuckle at the fact
that uh andrew just cited his sources
even on that statement
because you're so good at i don't know
how your memory works but um the only
person whose memories is better than joe
rogan is yours but my colleagues joke um
you know
pubmed sort of scrolls through through
my through my mind um also in science as
you know attribution is so baked into
what we do
and um and i think that it's interesting
because now spending a lot of time on
social media attribution is not as
common and um but in academia you learn
really early on that if you give a talk
about your data and you cite all these
amazing sources all it does is
make you look better right whereas in
social media and elsewhere in the
business sector it's almost like citing
other people people feel as if it's
going to take away some of the credit
all it does is place you in the company
of people that do really nice work so i
have tremend and i have genuine and
tremendous respect for tim he's been
about 10 years ahead on a huge number of
health related things and other things
an extremely kind person very thoughtful
person so it's also just a pleasure to
shine light on other people yeah well i
actually to push back i i know there's a
culture
of if you write a paper
standing on the shoulders of giants is a
powerful thing
but there's also a culture of not giving
credit
to the strongest idea in your paper and
instead say it's kind of or imply that
it's original
there is a culture of kind of not
celebrating others i think people
get most competitive in all walks of
life but especially in science when
they're as the closer they get and
exactly the thing they work on
and so there's this dance you know
there's a few researchers
in each of the individual little things
that you work on
if you're studying a particular kind of
ant you know that other [ __ ]
that also is studying that particular
ant and then you're not going to often
give credit for the brilliant ideas that
that
other researcher is doing and i think
one of the things you've discovered and
just as part of your nature and which is
why it's really great that you've
have an audience and you inspire others
to do the same as you celebrate that
other ant study here it's great and you
everybody wins it raises all boats
but that initial instinct to be like uh
what is it in borat like my neighbor my
neighbor gets a
a toaster i get a bigger toaster
yeah that mindset to you know it's not
that i'm not
competitive in certain domains but um
yeah i get great pleasure from um
sharing things that i find and um
i think that you know at the end of the
day
you're as strong as your community
and
you can build a wonderful community just
by
pointing out things that you love like
these are all just loves i see a paper i
love it only rarely do i think i wish we
had done that i usually think fantastic
now i can just focus on something else
because they checked off that box
you